(upbeat music)
- Hey, Drew, this is Bashir,
chef and advocate here in Toronto.
Today I'm sharing with you one
of my favorite and all-time recipe.
It's going to be a beef tartare,
showcasing you the intersectionality
between local food and diversity.
Come along and cook with me.
Take some oil,
adding in to our beets, sprinkling
in a little bit of salt.
Make a little bundle
and bake it in the oven
until they become really tender,
approximately 45 minutes to an hour.
So now my beets came of the oven,
allowed them to cool off.
I peeled them and with just a box grater,
I just grate them on the larger setting.
Now I'm going to add my butter,
chopped onions, and at the same time,
we're gonna also add berbere.
This is the staple of Ethiopian cooking.
So if you like food
that has a lot of flavor, aroma
and with a little bit of a heat on it,
berbere, it's the place to go.
I'm gonna add my beets,
a good pinch of salt
and then I'm going to de-glaze it
with some fresh orange juice.
Our beets had the chance to reduce.
There is not more orange juice.
So I will take my shiso leaves,
my injera has been in the oven
and turned into a crisp,
and I'm going to add a little
bit of the beets on top of it.
The best way to really
complement the sweetness
and the heat will be accentuating it
with a little bit of orange zest.
Drew, I really hope that you
enjoyed this Canadian dish.
My beets injera shiso with
a little bit of orange.
To the next one, cheers.
(upbeat music)